from goth to Rainbow via the grisliest
crimes the U.S Navy has ever faced who
else but ncis's Abby shudo Abby shudo's
style as seen on NCIS from season 1 to
season 15. often seems to clash with her
chipper personality but this forensic
scientist is ultimately a goth at heart
after all Abby loves not just death but
the supernatural tattoos and black
clothes and jewelry too maybe that's why
Abby became a fan favorite in short
order it's certainly what the minds
behind the character were aiming for
part of executive producer Donald
belisario's intent with Abby was to
create a positive depiction of a person
with tattoos and piercings peret told
CBS I think after all these years an
older generation might look at someone
with tattoos and instead of thinking
they're a thug they maybe think they're
a scientist she also discussed how many
girls followed in her character's
footsteps taking up Math and Science
courses in college because Abby made
these topics fun outside of work Abby is
a competent Plucky and kind-hearted
human being and part of her now iconic
Ensemble is her striking black hair
which she typically Fashions into
pigtails with bangs interestingly though
that hair color isn't the shade that
actor Polly Perrette was born with over
the years Polly perrette's jet black
locks may have become one of the
trademarks of abhishudo on NCIS but the
actor's hair is actually blonde to pull
off her look is Abby Perrette regularly
dyed it black with the help of hair and
makeup assistance who also gave her a
hand applying Abby's neck tattoo before
filming began each day she once told CBS
Sunday Morning that while working on the
series she actually ended up with dyed
Roots furthermore the actor tweeted in
2013 I dye my own hair black at home for
NCIS with store-bought dye I'm
absolutely not a salon girl however
heret revealed on The Queen Latifah show
that this had actually led to some
Health Complex locations she developed a
PPD allergy a condition that can happen
when you've been dying your hair black
for a long time during filming on NCIS
she woke up with her head swelling and
had to be rushed to the hospital but by
the time I got to the hospital it's like
half my head was this big and the other
half was like this big my eyes were
swollen shut and I'm like people need to
see this afterward the actor only used
black hairspray right up until she left
NCIS during its 15th season evidently
dying her hair black wasn't the best
move for Pauley Perrette but that's not
to say that dyeing her hair other colors
is out of the question with NCIS and
Abby shooter behind her she made the
Bold choice in 2021 to try out a brand
new look instead of choosing Just One
Hair Color though she chose multiple
revealing a vibrant rainbow hairstyle in
November of that year in a Twitter post
that showed off her new colorful
appearance for the world to see perett
wrote I'm a rainbow in the time since
debuting this bright hairdo she seems to
have kept up with it as her hair has
remained that way and a number of
subsequent social media posts with that
it doesn't look like she has any
intention of returning to life as Abby
on NCIS anytime soon and between her
serious PPD allergy and the tricky
nature of the fame that came with the
show who could blame her yes it seems
that Polly Perrette is doing just fine
away from NCIS and the Abbey shooter
role maybe someday she'll give both of
them another go but for the time being
she seems to be enjoying the freedom to
do whatever she'd like including with
her hair
[Music]
foreign
[Music]